[Music]
this this is the future we can stop
inventing things now this is the best
thing I've ever seen these German
engineers have created a multi rotor
flying machine and called it the
volocopter
[Music]
what makes it so amazing is that it can
be flown by virtually anybody in no
amount of time
I want a vole copter and I want it now
[Music]
I love the volocopter if they want
someone to test it out I would volunteer
the volocopter notched up nearly 5
million views online and is being hailed
as the future of commuter vehicles but
what makes this flying machine so unique
it takes 45 flight hours to get a normal
helicopter pilot's license
however in the volar copter because most
of the controls are handed over to
computer software it takes only about an
hour to master this machine the volar
copter is more like a drone than it is
like a helicopter because it's got 18
rotors it's incredibly stable by slowing
down the rotors on one side of the bhalo
copter there's more lift
comparatively on the other this causes
it to tip and allows it to steer to the
side landing any sort of airborne
vehicle is always one of the trickiest
parts of piloting it but the volar
copter is equipped with sensors meaning
it can detect the terrain how far away
it is and at the push of a button land
itself safely mind-blown
[Music]